nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système au tour
c'est-à-dire comment des agresseurs
ont-ils pu agresser 10/20 parfois trente
ans nous sommes loin du bout du chemin à
vous savez des institutions se réforment
lentement l'église peut-être encore plus
lentement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que la prise de conscience
est fait de tels scandales de tels
drames de telles tragédies dans la vie
oblige à la vérité
[Musique]
le laboratoire pfizer confiant que ses
livraisons de vaccins vont ralentir fin
janvier début février plusieurs pays
européens expriment leurs préoccupations
alors que les campagnes de vaccination
sont en cours en france
l'exécutif annonce qu'il devra ajuster
les rythme des vaccinations
plus de trois cent dix huit mille
personnes ont déjà reçu la première
injection le gouvernement espérait
jusque là dépassé le million de
personnes vaccinées d'ici la fin du mois
[Musique]
donald trump quittera washington
mercredi matin quelques heures avant
l'investiture de joe biden son
successeur démocrate qui a dévoilé hier
son plan de relance pour faire
redémarrer l'économie américaine
durement impactée par la pandémie
il prévoit que les américains touche
l'équivalent de 1153 euros par personne
en fonction de leurs revenus
les etats unis traversent leur pire
crise économique depuis les années 30
le décompte se poursuit en ouganda au
lendemain de l'élection présidentielle
les premiers résultats donnent le
président sortant et avaient ri à mutv
ni largement en tête il l'emporterait
avec près de 64% des voix contre plus de
28% pour son opposant bobby wine le
député qui revendique la victoire et
dénonce une mascarade
il assure se sentir menacé
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france c'est le temps
de faire des modifications dans le
processus de production et ainsi
augmenter la cadence pour les semaines
suivantes le laboratoire américain
pfizer justifie ainsi les retards de
livraison de vaccins des livraisons qui
vont bien ralentir fin janvier début
février
mais ce serait pour mieux attendre le
nouvel objectif déclaré de 2 milliards
de doses en 2021
les modifications à effectuer nécessite
selon le laboratoire des approbations
réglementaires supplémentaires dans une
lettre commune à la commission
européenne les ministres du danemark de
l'estonie de la finlande de la lituanie
de la lettonie mais aussi de la suède
ont exprimé leur sérieuse préoccupation
ursula von der leyen leur a répondu que
freezer a assuré que les doses attendu
par lieu au premier trimestre seront
bien livré comme prévu files heures
travaillent d'arrache-pied pour livrer
plus de doses que prévu initialement
cette année avec un nouvel objectif
déclaré de 2 milliards de doses en 2021
j'ai immédiatement appelé le directeur
général de pfizer
il m'a assuré que toutes les doses
garantie pour le premier trimestre à
destination des pays de l'union
européenne seront bien livré au premier
trimestre et pourtant paris annonce une
forte baisse l'exécutif devra ajuster le
rythme des vaccinations apprend t-on ce
soir la commission européenne par
ailleurs favorable à l'idée d'un
certificat de vaccination contre le
corps d'un virus sans certificat qui
soit mutuellement reconnu c'est ce
qu'indique ursula von der leyen
c'est un impératif médical mais c'est
une décision politique et juridique qui
doit être discuté au niveau européen
selon la présidente de la commission
réponse au chef du gouvernement grec qui
a appelé mardi l'ue a adopté un tel
dispositif pour donner un coup de pouce
à l'industrie du tourisme
le comité d'urgence de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé lui s'y oppose pour
le moment il met en avant trop
d'inconnues ch en termes d'efficacité
des vaccins pour réduire la transmission
du virus
la solution pour pallier le manque de
vaccin pourrait passer par un changement
de seringue
en belgique des seniors reçoivent
désormais leurs injections avec des
seringues
anti-gaspillage testé dans une maison de
retraite ce dispositif permet d'extraire
du même celle ci dose au lieu de cinq
de quoi vacciner vent pour cent une
personnes en plus on sera là si vous
perdez quand le piston est tout droit
vous perdez tout le liquide se trouve
dans le bout de la seringue et dans
l'aiguillé
ici vous avez des pistons qui sont
travaillés pour rentrer dans le but de
la soirée donc vous pouvez vraiment ne
pas gaspiller est vraiment tout ce qui
était une liquide le produit qui était
dans la seringue vallée dans le patient
moi je trouve que c'est une bonne chose
puisque ça permet de ne pas avoir de
pertes
donc ça permettra de vacciner 20% de
personnes en plus maintenant comme ça ça
s'est décidé au moment où la campagne de
vaccination était déjà en route
mais c'est à nous à trouver les 20 % de
personnes en plus pour qu'il n'y ait pas
de perte en france le ministre de la
santé a affirmé jusque là que plus d'un
million de vaccinations seront réalisés
d'ici fin janvier entre 2 millions 400
mille et 4 millions d'ici fin février en
fonction de l'arrivée du remède
fabriqués par astrazeneca olivier ans
qui était en déplacement à troyes
aujourd'hui plus de 318 mille personnes
ont reçu une injection dans trois jours
commencera à salade pour les plus de 75
ans le ministre de la santé a indiqué
que 8 133 centres étaient déjà ouverts à
la prise de rendez-vous dès demain le
couvre-feu à 18 heures sera appliquée à
l'ensemble dû territoire métropolitain
et pour au moins deux semaines c'est la
principale annonce hier de jean castex
pas de confinement pour le moment donc
mais de nouvelles restrictions qui
accompagne ce couvre feu généralisé
contrôle renforcée pour les voyageurs en
provenance d'un pays hors union
européenne ou encore protocole sanitaire
renforcée dans les écoles notamment dans
les cantines
alors comment réagissent les français
donc ça vous allez à la rencontre des
bordelais fiction distance moi je
travaille dans l'événementiel
professionnel
donc on a déjà pas mal impact et je
pense que ça va pas nous enlever grand
chose voilà en termes de travail bien on
a du mal à trouver du travail mais bon
ça n'a pas besoin de grand chose
si ça pouvait réduire la feccom un
confinement généralisée et b moi ça me
satisfait très satisfait ça très bien je
suis dans un responsable de magasin donc
on va devoir fermer plus tôt et on
s'adapte mais c'est ce que l'on fait
depuis de nombreux mois
donc voilà on va continuer en gardant le
sourire on est des chauffeurs de taxi en
fait à un bordeaux et donc du coup bas
déjà on n'a pas beaucoup de travail donc
on aura aussi moins en moins de travail
que d'habitude donc on va faire avec
pour tous les jeunes gens pour tous ceux
qui travaillent c'est vraiment une
catastrophe art
c'est vrai que la vie s'arrête on le
voit on le voit dans la ville s'est
jamais connu porto comme ça chauffe ça
change les boulons et pour les
commerçants c'est un nouveau coup dur
c'est ce que nous explique christian
baulme président de l'association
commerçants et artisans des métropoles
de france on est désespérés parce que
c'est l'heure la plus importante pour
les commerçants celle dernière heure 70
% du commerce se fait l'après midi et
70% se fait entre 16h30 et 19h donc ça
va être compliqué on va perdre en gros
20 % du chiffre d'affaires donc ça
devient dramatique mais ce n'est rien à
côté d'un confinement total où on aurait
plus du tout exercer voilà tu as fait la
partie pleine du verre moi je voudrais
dire à l'ensemble des pensé qu' il faut
commerce et le baccara il faut aller
chez les commerçants le matin que c'est
là où il ya le moins de monde donc c'est
là où on rencontrera le moins de
personnes avec le moindre ifs et ça
permettra aux commerçants de survivre en
arrêtant de compter sur les aides
publiques et car bien souvent les aides
publiques sont des prêts et les prix il
faudra les rembourser
en allemagne le nombre de décès liés au
virus a franchi le seuil des 40 mille
morts le confinement mis en place
pourrait être prolongé on fait le point
avec un peter oliver correspondant de
rtl à berlin mais les derniers chiffres
en provenance d'allemagne sont loin
d'être rassurants avec 22 1368 cas de
kobe 19 confirmé au cours de ces
dernières 24 heures et 1133 décès avec
ce chiffre
l'allemagne dépasse les 2 millions de
cas depuis le début de la pandémie
cela a poussé les autorités à agir avec
ce qu'on appelle ici un méga confinement
nous avons vu un confina au début de la
pandémie
un confit les alléger en automne et il
semble que nous entrons désormais dans
une nouvelle phase le méga confinement
mardi la chancelière angela merkel
rencontrera les seize dirigeants des
länder allemands afin d'essayer de
définir les mesures qui seront mises en
place une mesure en tout cas ne sera pas
adoptée c'est la fermeture des
transports publics
cette rumeur circulait jeudi soir le cd
ou l'union chrétienne démocrate le parti
majoritaire en allemagne qui fait partie
de la coalition au pouvoir a déclaré par
la voix de leur secrétaire général quand
cela ne faisait pas partie des options
envisagées que les transports en commun
continuerait de fonctionner l'autre
partie de la coalition au pouvoir et le
parti social démocrate un de leur
conseiller sanitaire car l'auteur bar
est un véritable expert dans son domaine
un professeur en épidémiologie et il a
eu de sévères mises en garde concernant
la pandémie et la mutation du virus à
laquelle nous assistons ces variants
britannique brésilien sud africain selon
lui il faut agir
chacune de ces mutations tu devrais être
considérée comme une pandémie en
elle-même et des mesures devraient être
prises et prises rapidement les
africaines obtient 270 millions de
vaccins pour le continent ils s'ajoutent
aux 600 millions de doses déjà promises
dans le cadre du programme kovacs de l'
oms
objectif affiché assurer un accès
équitable remède jusqu'ici relativement
épargnée par l'épidémie l'afrique et
certains pays en particulier traverse
une seconde vague virulente les variants
du gorna virus suscite l'inquiétude
le point en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la crise sanitaire et ses répercussions
économiques chez les états unis
traversent leur pire crise depuis les
années 30
à six jours de son investiture joe biden
a présenté hier son plan de relance pour
faire redémarrer l'économie américaine
chaque aux familles hausses de salaires
aides aux entreprises
les détails avec mathilde romagne en
1900 milliards de dollars pour relancer
l'économie
c'est le pari de joe biden quelques
jours avant de prendre les rênes du pays
le président élu dévoile un nouveau plan
de relance d'urgence
objectif sortir les etats-unis de la
situation liée à la pandémie de covin 19
la pire crise économique du pays depuis
des années 30
pour joe biden la reprise de l'économie
commence par l'accélération de la
campagne de vaccination
le programme de vaccination aux états
unis a été un échec lamentable jusqu'à
présent demain j'établirai notre plan de
vaccination pour corriger le tir et
atteindre notre objectif de 100 millions
de vaccinations à la fin de mai son
premier jour demande pour que les
parents puissent retourner au travail
joe biden s'est engagé à rouvrir les
écoles dans les 100 premiers jours de
son mandat
il promet également des aides pour les
familles américaines
notre plan de relance comprend également
une aide immédiate aux américains les
plus touchés et les plus démunis nous
allons terminer le travail constituant à
fournir un total de 2000 $ en espèces
aux personnes qui en ont le plus besoin
les 600 dollars déjà alloués ne sont
tout simplement pas suffisant joe biden
n'a pas manqué une occasion de tacler
son prédécesseur mais cela ne
l'empêchent pas de reprendre à son
compte le made in america marque de
fabrique de donald
nous utiliserons l'argent des
contribuables pour reconstruire
l'amérique nous achèterons des produits
américains
soutenant des millions d'emplois
industriels américains renforcer notre
compétitivité dans un monde de plus en
plus compétitif je sais que ce que je
viens de décrire n'est pas sans coûts
mais ne pas le faire nous coûtera cher
reste à joe biden de convaincre le
congrès de voter ce texte et débloquer
les 1900 milliards de dollars
nécessaires
moins d'une semaine avant d'entrer à la
maison blanche il lui faudra notamment
gagné la confiance des élus républicains
qui avaient déjà voté au printemps
dernier le plan de 2200 milliards de
dollars du président trust donald trump
qui quittera washington mercredi matin
quelques heures avant l'investiture de
son successeur démocrate joe biden
washington se prépare à cette cérémonie
dans un climat particulier l'assaut du
capitole et dans toutes les mémoires
plus de 200 suspects ont été jusque-là
identifié par les autorités
et selon le parquet fédéral américain
certains émeutiers voulais capturer et
assassiné des élus al'approche du 20
janvier le dispositif de sécurité a donc
été renforcée ce qu'on retrouve sur
place à washington
notre envoyé spécial thomas bonnin on
est à plusieurs centaines de mètres du
capitole et on ne peut pas s'approcher
davantage parce que le périmètre de
sécurité autour du bâtiment a été
élargie renforcée avec notamment c'est
palissade qui sont surveillés nuitées
jours par des membres de la garde
nationale c'est d'ailleurs la nouveauté
principale de ce dispositif de sécurité
en vue de l'investiture de joe biden
la présence de membres de la garde
nationale qui continuent à arriver ici à
washington on les voit notamment arrivé
dans des cars ou plusieurs dizaines de
soldats arrivent ici dans la capitale
fédérale pour être déployés pour ces
opérations de maintien de l'ordre il
devrait être autour de dix mille pour
cette journée du 20 janvier un chiffre
qui pourrait même doubler en cas de
nécessité évidemment l'objectif des
autorités c'est d'empêcher toute
manifestation violente et surtout ne pas
voir se reproduire les mêmes images que
le 6 janvier dernier des images qui ont
choqué les etats-unis avec notamment
donc ces manifestants qui sont
entré à l'intérieur du capitole l'une
des conséquences de ce déploiement
conséquent des membres de la garde
nationale ce sont ces images on voit des
soldats dormir à même le sol à
l'intérieur du capitole
ces images ont beaucoup circulé sur les
réseaux sociaux ces dernières heures et
elles ont choqué un certain nombre
d'internautes au point que le district
de columbia a finalement publié un
communiqué afin d'apporter quelques
précisions
la police du capitole a réservé des
espaces pour le repos des gardes
nationaux en service entre leur tour de
garde
pour être clair ce n'est pas là qu'il
sont logés une fois leur service terminé
le travail de notre personnel de
sécurité s'organisent par poste afin
qu'il soit toujours vif et vigilants et
qu'ils puissent avoir des moments de
repos alors que d'autres assurent la
veille il y a à cette note du fbi a
publié ces derniers jours par des médias
américains et qui fait état de menaces
de manifestations violentes avec des
individus armés qui pourraient
potentiellement venir ici à washington
pour perturber la passation de pouvoir
il faut noter que dans le district de
columbia ici le port d'armes
mais pas autorisés la question
maintenant est de savoir si les
autorités pour ont su faire suffisamment
de contrôle pour empêcher un individu
muni d'une arme de s'approcher du
capitole les autorités en attendant
recommandent aux habitants d'éviter le
centre-ville et la plateforme airbnb a
même annulé toutes les réservations ici
à washington pour ne pas permettre à de
potentiels manifestants violents de
s'approcher un peu trop près du capitole
ces menaces ne se concentre pas
uniquement sur la ville de washington
puisque son selon la même note du fbi y
aillent tous les états des états unis
sont concernés avec de possibles
manifestations là encore des
manifestations violentes notamment près
des capitals qui sont présents dans tous
les états américains
vous l'aurez compris à cinq jours de la
passation de pouvoirs et malgré l'appel
au calme ce mercredi de donald trump
les etats unis sont en alerte maximale
au pays basque le premier ministre
confirme sa démission et celle de son
gouvernement une décision liée à un
scandale des milliers de familles accusé
à tort de fraude est contrainte de
rembourser les allocations familiales
touché pendant plusieurs années
nombre d'entre elles ont également fait
l'objet d'un profilage ethnique sur la
base de leur double nationalité
cette démission intervient à deux mois
des élections législatives
nous sommes du même avis si tout le
système a échoué seul la responsabilité
conjointe peut être assumée et cela a
conduit à la conclusion que j'ai
maintenant offert au roi la démission de
tout le cabinet direction maintenant
l'espagne madrid a bien du mal à se
remettre de la tempête philomena les
rues de la capitale espagnole sont
toujours bloqués ce qui empêche les
éboueurs d'accéder à la ville résultat
les rues sont jonchées d'ordures au
grand dam des habitants solène gaudin la
neige recouverte par les ordures dans
les rues de madrid les poubelles
s'amoncellent jusqu'à empêcher les
passons de circuler c'est un quartier où
il ya beaucoup de personnes âgées c'est
devenu très compliqué de marcher dans la
rue il ya plein de cartons il ya
tellement de cette fois fini par devoir
quitter le trottoir pour marcher sur la
chaussée
même s'il y a déjà de plus en plus de
voitures qui circulent les fortes
intempéries de samedi dernier ont rendu
impossible l'accès aux rues de la
capitale espagnole alors pour tenter de
dégager la route
les madrilènes retroussent leurs manches
il dégage seulement les rues principales
celle ci comme vous pouvez le voir
tendre est recouverte de neige même s'il
ya un bar ouvert le service de ramassage
des ordures n'est pas passer non plus
depuis vendredi dernier
nous accumulons les déchets chez nous
car les camions ne peuvent pas passer
les habitants invitent leurs voisins à
ne plus jeter leurs poubelles dans la
rue selon les médias locaux jusqu'à 9000
tonnes de déchets n'ont pas pu être
ramassés
c'est à tel point que les commerçants
craignent de ne plus pouvoir ouvrir
leurs magasins
dans un jour et demi les ordures vont
recouvrir la vitrine simone serre ont
tous un peu les coudes
je pense qu'il est possible de dégager
un espace pour permettre aux gens de
traverser tous ensemble je pense qu'on
peut y arriver mais c'est très très
compliqué samedi dernier
madrid a été balayée par la tempête
philomena la ville n'avait pas connu de
chute de neige aussi importante depuis
50 ans en ouganda le décompte des
résultats de la présidentielle se
poursuit
les premiers chiffres donnent le
président sortant yoweri museveni est
largement en tête il l'emporterait avec
près de 64% des voix contre un peu plus
de 28% pour son opposant un bobby brown
ce dernier qui revendique pourtant la
victoire et dénonce une mascarade
françois xavier lambert fusil au mans
les policiers quadrillent les rues de
kampala alors que les résultats de la
présidentielle se font toujours attendre
le calme prédomine dans la capitale
ougandaise
selon les premières estimations publiées
par la commission électorale le
président sortant yoweri museveni
devancerait largement son principal
rival bobby wine mais cette version est
contredite par l'ex chanteur qui affirme
avoir remporté le scrutin
devant la presse il a dénoncé des
fraudes et assuré avoir été menacé par
des militaires plusieurs de nos numéros
de téléphone y compris le mien et celui
de ma femme ont été désactivés ils ont
été déconnectés illégalement
l'armée déployée partout la dictature
est en panique dans les prochaines
heures
je m'adresserai à la nation en espérant
pouvoir dire à notre peuple
comment aller de l'avant mais en
définitive nous sommes en train de
renverser un dictateur
de son côté le président sortant aux
grandes et continue d'afficher sa
sérénité
yoweri museveni a voté en toute
décontraction vêtu de son chapeau blanc
le chef de l'état au pouvoir depuis
trente cinq ans n'a jamais perdu une
élection il peut compter sur la
puissance de son parti le mouvement de
résistance nationale
dans ce contexte de nombreux électeurs
se disent résignés
hier soir bobby wine était en tête mais
ce matin j'ai entendu dire que le
président moussavi ni était un peu
devant
je suis choquée mais je ne pense pas
qu'il y aura de changement de président
je pense que rien ne va se passer parce
que les gens ont peur bien sûr il
peuvent pas faire des motos quoi que ce
soit de mal la légitimité du scrutin
suscite également l'inquiétude de
l'union européenne des etats-unis et de
l'onu qui ont appelé les différents
candidats à respecter le processus
démocratique
les résultats de cette présidentielle
couplée à des législatives seront connus
ce samedi un record en france où le
controversé préfet de police de paris
didier lallement ainsi que plusieurs
hauts magistrats sont visés par une
enquête pour faux témoignage des propos
qu'ils ont tenus au cours d'auditions de
la commission sur l'indépendance du
pouvoir judiciaire
les explications de katia technique le
préfet de police didier lallement et sur
le coup d'une enquête pour faux
témoignage
quatre autres personnalités issues de la
haute magistrature sont également visés
dans cette procédure initiée par le
parquet de nanterre en cause de faux
témoignage lors de la commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur l'indépendance
de la justice présidée par le député
insoumis ugo bernalicis en septembre il
avait saisi le procureur de la
république de paris pour de supposées
parjure en effet toutes les
personnalités qui s'expriment devant les
commissions parlementaires prêté serment
monsieur je vous invite donc à lever la
main droite est à dire je le jure je le
jure je jure monsieur le président mes
propos contestés de didier lallement
concerne l'attitude des forces de
l'ordre lors des manifestations non
autorisées didier lallement avait
expliqué qu'il avait fait mettre en
garde à vue dès gilet jaune ou autres
militants antiracistes qui avait appelé
à se regrouper dans la rue sans avoir
l'autorisation
alors go bernalicis avait demandé s'il
avait fait de même avec les
syndicalistes policiers qui avaient
organisé des manifestations non
autorisées à paris en juin
voici la réponse de didier lallement
vous voyez pas de sujets sur les
manifestations appelées par les
organisations syndicales quand elles ne
sont pas déclarés ou je pense notamment
manifestation des policiers récemment la
nuit depuis trois nuits de suite devant
les institutions
je n'ai pas trouvé les organisateurs
n'était pourtant pas très difficile de
les identifier dans le cortège pour rémi
heitz les propos litigieux concerne une
note intitulée permanence gilet jaune
contenant des instructions qu'aurait
donné le procureur elle conseillait de
ne pas lever la garde à vue pour
certains manifestants avant la fin de la
mobilisation
à l'époque le syndicat national de la
magistrature avait dénoncé une atteinte
aux libertés individuelles un
détournement de la garde à vue
voici ce qu'explique rémi heitz je vais
vous répondre très clairement sur cette
note
déjà vous observerez que cette note
personne ne l'a vu c'est ce qui est un
peu curieux c'est que cette note
elle n'existe pas pour être clair le
procureur de la république de paris n'a
pas signé une note avec des instructions
à ses collègues en leur disant de faire
telle ou telle chose non pourtant un peu
plus tard rémy heitz admet avoir fourni
un mémento de bonnes pratiques
concernant notamment la garde à vue ce
qui revient strictement au même
et puis trois autres hautes
personnalités de la magistrature ont été
signalés par ugo bernalicis cette fois
ci dans le cadre de la sphère fillon
mais voyons ce que pense le député du
nord insoumis de cette enquête c'est une
bonne nouvelle en soi une enquête soit
ouverte alors ça sera à charge et à
décharge ne serait pas quelle sera
l'issue est à la limite peu importe
l'issue l'objectif pour le parlementaire
que je suis le président de commission
denquête que j'étais je les obstacles
indépendance du pouvoir j'ai dit c'est
que on prenne au sérieux la
représentation nationale la santé
nationaux ce qu'est une commission
denquête parce que qui on peut venir
devant une commission denquête mentir et
repartir comme si de rien n'était enfin
tout ça ne sert plus à rien on est quand
même la représentation nationale
il existe un précédent récent alexandre
benallal ancien monsieur sécurité d'
emmanuel macron s'était exprimé devant
une commission sénatoriale
eh bien les parlementaires avaient
estimé qu'il avait peut-être tenu des
propos mensongers dont il l'avait
signalé
pour cela ils pouvaient risquer jusqu'à
cinq ans de prison et 75000 euros
d'amendé
mais finalement le parquet de paris
avait décidé de classer l affaire sans
suite
est ce que le parquet de nanterre où est
dépaysé la sphère sera moins clément s à
la fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi je vous retrouve dans une
trentaine de minutes pour un nouveau
journal à tout à l'heure
mais
[Musique]
comment on peut expliquer qu'elle un
groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire des à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle crève